يعود تاريخها الى زمن قبيلتي تصم وجديس اي
عمرها نحو ثلاثه الاف عام
الحني كانت مستوطنه يقول باحثون ثريه
بعماره منازلها واسواقها وابالها على
الرغم من ان المسوحات حتى اليوم تقول ان
مستوطنه الحني في حجر اليمامه تحتل مساحه
كيلومتر مربع ونصف الا ان الابحاث التي
يطالب بها الباحثون لهذه القريه الاثريه
جنوب مدينه الرياض قد تكشف عن مفاجات
كثيره وربما تكون احداها ان حدود الحني
اوسع من ذلك بكثير
نعم هذا الان نموذج قديم المدينه حجر
اليمامه يقدم الانسان له التصور قبل 1500
سنه النظام العمراني الموجود في حجر
اليمامه هذا النظام مماثل له وانا اذكر
الحقيقه قبل عشرين سنه اكتشف احد الباحثين
الزملاء الاستاذ محمد الحمود لو الحقيقه
الفضل بعد الله عز وجل في اكتشاف ايضا هذه
المنطقه ان يتمنى ايضا ان تزاد الحقيقه
البحوث واجراء الاكتشافات عليها لكنها
الان هذا التصور القديم المباني المعماريه
الطرز المعماريه الموجوده في حجر اليمامه
العاصمه التاريخيه لمدينه الرياض هذا احد
النماذج التي ننتبه لها الحقيقه وتقدم
ايضا لنا الفكره عن البناء العمراني في
مدينه حجر اليمامه طيب
الان يا دكتور نرى هذا البناء من الحجر
حجر الجير الموجود في ظاهره طويق وفي جبل
صحيح اذا البناء قوي السؤال لاحظ في
القرون اللاحقه الرياض وقبل ما تكون اسمها
الرياض يبنون بالطين فقط صحيح لماذا تحول
البناء من حجر قوي الى طين هل هو الوضع
الاقتصادي هو هذه الوضع الاقتصادي هو عامل
اساسي لا شك وايضا الانسان ابن بيئته
فاقرب الاشياء الان للاستخدامات البيئيه
نجدها ايضا الحجاره وهناك ايضا الحجاره
مهنه قديمه وايضا وردت لها في المصادر
التاريخيه هناك مهن معروفه منها مهنه ايضا
الذين يقطعون الحصى مثلا ومهن معينه يعني
هذه الجزء الان الموجود في هذه المنطقه
تقدم لنا ايضا جزء من التصور العام كما
ذكرنا المباني الموجوده في حجر اليمامه
طبعا هذه الان بعد دخول الرمال من اكثر من
20 سنه ادت ايضا الى ارتفاع النموذج هذا
احنا داخلين فيه وايضا تجد النموذج الطروز
المعماريه للبيوت القديمه وهذا احدها يعني
الان نجد فيه هنا نجد التنور القديم
التنور القديم الذي يستخدم للطعام من اكثر
من 1500 سنه هذه بقاياها الان موجوده
[موسيقى]